vous placez info intox mais
c'est avec vous en tenez saint léger
pour soir en bon sens la vue avant sur
atos on s'intéresse ce soir à
l'afghanistan près de six mois après
l'arrivée des talibans au pouvoir des
internautes font état de destruction
massive de téléphone portable en lui des
internautes qui se base sur ces images
on va les découvrir ensemble des hommes
qui pour certains sont en uniforme et
qui écrase sciemment avec leurs pieds
vous voyez des centaines de téléphones
portables des images que l'on trouve
notamment via cette publication youtube
que l'on voit ici donc avec le titre en
question on voit également que cette
publication a déjà récolté plus de 30000
vue et elle a été publiée le 15 janvier
dernier ces images elles ont été aussi
aux reprises dans différentes
publications que ce soit sur instagram
facebook ou encore twitter cumulant là
encore à chaque fois des dizaines de
milliers de vues et certains internautes
en plus de relayer ces images ont
affirmé que les téléphones portables
étaient interdits en afghanistan sous
peine de lourdes sanctions en
l'occurrence selon cet internaute que
les récalcitrants était condamné à la
peine de mort vous allez heureusement
nous expliquer pourquoi c'est faux oui
alors d'une part l'image est belle elle
est bien authentique mais ces téléphones
et n'ont pas été détruits en afghanistan
mais au pakistan explications on va
revenir sur cette vidéo virale à la 15e
seconde où vous avez ce drapeau que l'on
voit sur l'uniforme en question ce
drapeau c'est le drapeau pakistanais
c'est donc un premier élément qui m'est
le plus la puce à l'oreille et en
cherchant ensuite ces mots-là pakistan
destruction et falls en anglais donc les
des mots clés on trouve notamment une
vidéo plus longue celle ci c'est la
troisième occurrence et elle nous ramène
au 29 décembre elle a été publiée à le
29 décembre sur youtube et la légende
nous dit alors vous voyez ici des images
similaires je dis pas identique je dis
bien similaires et on reconnaît
d'ailleurs on va revenir légèrement en
arrière le conteneur bleus que l'on
voyait dans l'image inverse virale et la
légende nous dit quoi elle nous dit on
va regarder un petit peu plus bas qu'il
s'agit d'une cérémonie de destruction de
bouteilles saisies par la douane à
karachi on va pousser la recherche un
petit peu plus loin on va taper elles
mêmes mots clés que tout que tout à
l'heure mais en ourdou donc l'une des
langues du pakistan et on tombe sur des
vidéos similaires dans différentes
publications notamment sur facebook et
c'est la presse qui va nous donner un
petit peu plus de contexte notamment ce
journal pakistanais en anglais qui nous
apprend que cette destruction elle a
bien eu lieu le 29 décembre à karachi
mais avec les téléphones portables il y
a eu et fait effectivement d'autres
marchandises de l'alcool de la drogue
des cigarettes qui ont été détruits car
issues de la contrebande un butin d'une
modique somme quand même de 29 millions
d'euros oui ce que la première
information partiellement vrai dans la
mesure où est ce que les téléphones sont
vraiment interdit aujourd'hui d'un
organiste alors non ils sont autorisés
dans le pays ça a été confirmé par des
sources locales aux observateurs de
france 24 les talibans eux-mêmes les
utilisent
mais avant leur arrivée au pouvoir en
août dernier c'est vrai il était
interdit dans certaines provinces
notamment celle de celle ci c'est de
danse entre ces races ni dans le centre
du pays c'est ce que nous rapporte le
journal local gandhara que l'on voit ici
c'était en août 2001 le journal qui vous
voyez dans son titre évoque aussi la
musique on va y revenir un petit peu
plus n'a pour ce qui est des téléphones
portables il n'est pas rare toutefois
que ceux des journalistes ou des membres
de membres des ong soient détruits en
raison du risque évidemment à qu'il
représente pour pouvoir et une fois aux
commandes du pays les talibans ont aussi
fait un peu de ménage dans contenu de
certains téléphones de leurs concitoyens
la recherche d'éléments compromettants
concernant qui pouvait établir des liens
avec les occidentaux évidemment surtout
les américains mais aussi la musique
donc la musique mon y revient et si elle
n'est pas religieux cette musique on le
sait les interdits dans tout le pays
encore récemment des vidéos différentes
vidéos d'instruments brûlés ou tout
simplement détruits on le voit ici on a
effectivement circulé des destructions
en public l'exemple de ce sens il est
assez simple ils nous montrent
finalement qu'une fois de plus en
voulant surfer sur un contexte réel qui
est l'arrivée des talibans et avec elle
aussi l'arrivée de loi liberticide c'est
vrai et bien des photos
décontextualisés vont véhiculer des
messages erronés d'ailleurs depuis leur
arrivée au pouvoir
des talibans étaient victimes si on peut
dire de plusieurs un fox à leur encontre
ajout renvoie sur le site des
observateurs pour voir plusieurs
exemples merci beaucoup anthony merci
pour cette chronique on peut la
retrouver sur vos réseaux sociaux merci
à vous votre attention aux marques une
très courte pause entre trouve en
quelques minutes a tout de suite
[Musique]